This week marks 20 years since the September 11, 2001, terrorist attacks on the World Trade Center and the Pentagon. Nearly 3,000 people died that day. Millions more watched the planes hit the buildings. Many saw the attacks on live TV. And two decades later, those images remained seared in the nation's memory. Researchers call this kind of shared disaster a collective trauma. For decades, they've studied how collective trauma affects individuals and communities. mental and even physical health? Who is most at risk after a collective trauma event? How long do
本周是2001年9月11日世界贸易中心和五角大楼恐怖袭击事件发生20周年。那天有近3000人丧生。数百万人目睹了飞机撞击大楼的画面。许多人通过电视直播看到了袭击过程。二十年后，这些画面依然深深烙印在国民的记忆中。研究人员将这种共同的灾难称为集体创伤。几十年来，他们一直在研究集体创伤如何影响个人和社区。心理甚至生理健康？集体创伤事件后，谁的风险最大？这些影响会持续多久？
the effects of such trauma last? And after two decades, are we still dealing with the trauma of 9-11 today? What did we learn in the aftermath of 9-11 that can inform our response to the COVID-19 pandemic, hurricanes, wildfires, and other large-scale disasters? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Roxanne Cohen-Silver, a professor of psychological science, medicine, and public health at the University of California, Irvine. She studies how people cope with traumatic life events, including both personal and collective traumas. She was the principal investigator of a multi-year study of the national
这种创伤的影响会持续多久？二十年后的今天，我们是否仍在应对“9·11”带来的创伤？我们在“9·11”之后学到了什么，可以为我们应对新冠疫情、飓风、野火和其他大规模灾难提供参考？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯。今天的嘉宾是加州大学欧文分校心理科学、医学和公共卫生教授罗克珊·科恩-西尔弗博士。她研究人们如何应对创伤性生活事件，包括个人创伤和集体创伤。她是“9·11”恐怖袭击对国家心理和生理健康影响的多年期研究的首席研究员。
impact of the September 11th terror attacks on the nation's mental and physical health. She has also studied the short and long-term effects of disasters, such as earthquakes, fires, school shootings, and war. Most recently, she and her colleagues have been studying the COVID-19 pandemic and what she calls the cascading collective traumas of 2020 and 2021. We'll talk about those today as well. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Silver. Thank you so much.
她还研究过地震、火灾、校园枪击和战争等灾难的短期和长期影响。最近，她和同事们一直在研究新冠疫情，以及她所说的2020年和2021年接连发生的集体创伤。今天我们也会谈到这些。感谢您参加我们的节目，西尔弗博士。非常感谢。
It's a pleasure to be here. As I mentioned a few moments ago, you led several multi-year studies on the effects of 9-11 on Americans' mental and physical health. Can you tell us about that research? What were some of your chief findings? And what did we learn about collective trauma and the aftermath of 9-11? Thank you very much for that question. My colleagues and I began in the days after the September 11th terrorist attacks to study a large representative sample of Americans who were followed for about three years. those individuals were from across the United States. We had people, of course, who were from the New York area, as well as people in every state of the country. And we started a few days after the 9-11 attacks to ask people about their exposure to the attacks, whether or not they knew anybody who was in the World Trade Center,
很高兴来到这里。正如我刚才提到的，您领导了几项关于“9·11”对美国人心理和生理健康影响的多年期研究。能给我们介绍一下这项研究吗？您有哪些主要发现？我们从“9·11”后的集体创伤中学到了什么？非常感谢您提出这个问题。我和同事们在“9·11”恐怖袭击发生后的几天里就开始研究一个具有代表性的大型美国人群体，并对他们进行了大约三年的跟踪调查。这些受访者来自美国各地。当然，我们既有来自纽约地区的人，也有来自全国各州的人。我们在“9·11”袭击发生几天后开始询问人们对袭击的接触程度，是否认识在世贸中心、
or the Pentagon or on one of the airplanes, whether or not they themselves were in New York City or Washington, D.C., whether they knew anybody who was presumably, who was lost and presumably at that point, killed by the attacks. And we also asked people the amount of television that they watched in the first few days after the 9-11 attacks. You may remember, or those who can remember that day, know that in general, most regular programming was suspended with a very intense media focus on the 9-11 attacks and the attempts to find survivors in the rubble and also to understand a little bit of more about what happened. We followed these individuals in our study. It was about 3,500 individuals.
五角大楼或其中一架飞机上的人，他们自己当时是否在纽约市或华盛顿特区，是否认识当时失踪并被推定已在袭击中遇难的人。我们还询问了人们在“9·11”袭击后最初几天观看电视的时长。您可能还记得，或者那些记得那一天的人都知道，当时常规节目基本停播，媒体高度聚焦于“9·11”袭击，试图在废墟中寻找幸存者，并试图进一步了解发生了什么。我们在研究中跟踪了这些人，大约有3500人。
We followed them, as I said, for three years. And we looked at their emotional responses, their concerns, their ongoing concerns about terrorism. And we also measured some of their physical health complaints, those physical health complaints that developed over the next three years. And in addition, during that period of time that we studied people, we assessed their ongoing, as I said, concerns about terrorism, but their continued exposure to personal traumatic experiences like did they lose a loved one to cancer? Did they themselves get sick? Did they witness violence? And we explored the impact of people's exposure to 9-11. the impact of exposure to other events in their lives and how that impacted their psychological
正如我所说，我们跟踪了他们三年。我们观察了他们的情绪反应、他们对恐怖主义的持续担忧。我们还测量了他们的一些生理健康投诉，即在接下来的三年里出现的生理健康问题。此外，在我们研究期间，我们评估了他们对恐怖主义的持续担忧，以及他们是否持续接触个人创伤经历，比如他们是否因癌症失去了亲人？他们自己是否生病了？他们是否目睹了暴力？我们探讨了人们接触“9·11”事件的影响，以及接触生活中其他事件的影响，以及这些如何影响了他们接下来几年的心理状态。
state over the next several years. How did it impact them? What happened to these people over three years? We were surprised to see the potent effect of media exposure on people's psychological and physical health over time. We argued that individuals did not have. have to be directly exposed to the events of 9-11. That is, they did not need to be at the World Trade Center or around the buildings to have been impacted by the events of 9-11. And these effects that you saw, they were higher than they might have been. Did you have a control that you were measuring them against? Well, what we did was look at individuals who indicated that they watched the attacks live on television.
这对他们有什么影响？这三年里这些人经历了什么？我们惊讶地发现，媒体接触对人们长期的心理和生理健康有着强大的影响。我们认为，个人不必直接接触“9·11”事件。也就是说，他们不需要身处世贸中心或大楼周围，也会受到“9·11”事件的影响。您看到的这些影响比预期的要高。您有进行对照测量吗？我们所做的是观察那些表示自己在电视上直播观看了袭击过程的个人。
So those who can remember those days know that the second plane hit the World Trade Center, and that was broadcast live. And individuals could also see the buildings fall live on television. And we could juxtapose. those individuals who said that they had seen the attacks live on television as compared to those who did not. We found that those who did witness the events of 9-11 live on television were more likely to be exhibiting stress responses, both psychological and physical stress responses, and more likely to develop physical health complaints over the next three years.
所以那些记得那些日子的人都知道，第二架飞机撞向世贸中心时是现场直播的。人们也可以在电视上直播看到大楼倒塌。我们可以将那些表示自己在电视上直播观看了袭击的人与那些没有观看的人进行对比。我们发现，那些在电视上直播目睹了“9·11”事件的人，更有可能表现出压力反应，包括心理和生理压力反应，并且在接下来的三年里更有可能出现生理健康问题。
New onset physical health complaints. So health concerns that had not been present previously. Let me say one very important part of our study, because it was a longitudinal study, that is we repeatedly studied the same individuals over time, we could explore the development of physical health complaints. So we know where they were physically and psychologically before the attacks. We had data that were collected on those individuals. And we could monitor the new onset of psychological and physical concerns.
新出现的生理健康问题。也就是说，以前不存在的健康问题。让我说明我们研究中一个非常重要的部分，因为这是一项纵向研究，也就是说我们随着时间的推移反复研究同一批人，我们可以探索生理健康问题的演变。所以我们知道他们在袭击前后的生理和心理状况。我们掌握了这些人的数据。我们可以监测心理和生理问题的首次出现。
It is also the case that because we began our study within a few days, after the 9-11 attacks, we were not asking people to reconstruct their memory of where they were at that time. We were actually measuring that about five days after the attacks. And so we could say how many hours over the past week have you spent watching media as opposed to me asking you 20 years later, how many hours do you think you were spending? I will say that of our nationally representative sample of individuals, about 60% reported within those, within a few days after the 9-11 attacks, that they did witness some portion of the attacks live on television. So it was about 60% witnessed either the second plane hitting the World Trade Center or the Bill
同样，因为我们在“9·11”袭击发生后的几天内就开始了研究，所以我们不是要求人们重构当时的记忆。我们实际上是在袭击发生后大约五天测量了这些数据。所以我们可以问“过去一周你花了多少小时看媒体”，而不是20年后问你“你觉得你花了多少小时”。我要说的是，在我们具有全国代表性的样本中，约60%的人在“9·11”袭击发生后的几天内报告说，他们确实在电视上直播目睹了袭击的部分过程。所以大约60%的人目睹了第二架飞机撞击世贸中心或大楼倒塌，约40%的人是事后才得知袭击事件的。在我们的样本中，约有5%的人当时身处纽约、华盛顿特区或宾夕法尼亚州，或者当时正与大楼里的某人通电话，或者身处该地区并直接目睹了事件。那么，20年过去了，您认为作为一个国家，我们今天是否仍在感受“9·11”的影响，还是说它在我们的脑海中已经淡去了？你知道，这非常非常难说，因为过去20年里我们社会的许多方面都发生了变化。在“9·11”袭击期间，人们了解悲剧事件的主要方式是
buildings fall, and about 40% learned about the attacks afterwards. In our sample, we had about 5% of individuals who were either in New York or Washington, D.C., or Pennsylvania, or had been on the phone with somebody in one of the buildings, or had been in the area and had witnessed the events directly. So here we are 20 years later. Do you think that as a country, we're still feeling the effects of 9-11 today, or has it receded in our minds by now? You know, it's very, very difficult to say because so many aspects of our society have changed over the last 20 years. During the 9-11 attacks, the main way in which people learned about tragic events was via
电视。当然，我们还有广播和印刷媒体。但20年后，由于媒体环境的巨大变化，我们可以在几秒钟内了解世界各地发生的事件。所以世界变了，由于获取全球内容变得容易，世界在某些方面变小了。许多其他事情也同时发生了变化。将这些社会变化直接与“9·11”袭击联系起来非常困难。然而，那些年龄足够大、记得“9·11”之前生活的人也记得，过去人们可以毫无阻碍地穿过机场。你可以在飞机起飞前10分钟跑到登机口。
television. We also, of course, had radio and print media. But now, 20 years later, we learn about events across the world in seconds because of a very different media landscape. So the world has changed, has gotten smaller in some ways because of the easy access to content across the world. Many other things have changed simultaneously. it's very difficult to link those societal changes to the 9-11 attacks directly. However, those who are old enough to remember prior to 9-11, also remember that one used to be able to go through the airport without any barriers. You could run to your plane 10 minutes before the plane.
我过去经常那样做。我讨厌在飞机起飞前在机场待超过10分钟。现在我们要在机场登机口前排长队，而且毫无怨言。我们这些记得过去的人现在这样做时没有任何抗议，因为我们非常清楚地记得“9·11”事件。整个国土安全部就是从“9·11”中衍生出来的。在“9·11”袭击之前，美国对恐怖主义的担忧几乎不存在。所以过去几十年来发生了太多的变化。将这些变化与那几天的事件或几年后的事件联系起来非常非常困难。
And I used to do that quite a bit. I hated to be in the airport more than 10 minutes before my plane. We now stand in long lines without protest prior to going to an airport gate. And those of us who are old enough to remember previously do that now without any protest because we very much remember the events of 9-11. The entire Department of Homeland Security grew out of 9-11. The concern about terrorism was relatively non-existent in the United States prior to the 9-11 attacks. So there are so many things that have changed over the last several decades. And it's very, very difficult to link it to the events of those days or,
我们国家在政治上也变得更加两极分化。社交媒体的出现改变了我们彼此交流的方式。所有这些事情在过去的二十年里都巧合地发生了变化。所以我发现很难将这些直接与“9·11”联系起来。我认为那是历史学家的角色。作为一名心理学家，我不是历史学家，我无法谈论那些事件的历史影响。我当然知道过去20年里我们的社会确实存在许多差异。实际上，这些提醒每天都伴随着我们，只是你所说的是，我们没有建立起这种关联。所以脱鞋、通过金属探测器以及今天我们必须做的所有其他事情已经变成了正常生活。
the events of the few years later. We've also become more polarized in our country politically. The onset of social media has changed the way in which we communicate with one another. All of those things have coincidentally changed during those two decades. So I find it difficult to link those directly to 9-11. I think that's really the role of historians as a psychologist. I can't, I'm not a historian, I can't speak to the historical impact of the events of those days. I certainly know that there are just many differences in our society in the last 20 years. In effect, these are reminders that are with us every day, except that what you're saying is that we're not making the associations. So it has become normal life to take our shoes off and go through metal detectors and everything else that we have to do today.
绝对是这样。而且没有人抗议。同样，当年轻人去参加音乐会时，他们会打开手提包，女性打开手提包，男性习惯了通过金属探测器。几十年前根本不会发生这种情况。在“9·11”之前不会发生。所有这些变化都是对我们国土上恐怖主义担忧的直接回应。让我问你一个相关的问题。为什么要纪念悲剧事件的周年纪念日？这些是会带回创伤，还是能帮助人们处理和应对它，或者两者兼有？这是一个非常有趣的问题。我认为非常清楚的一点是，媒体甚至像这样的采访在无意中再次带出了这些事件。我个人非常不高兴看到媒体上播放“9·11”袭击的画面，那些血腥的画面。多年来，在“9·11”周年纪念日，我们会看到世贸中心的照片，
Absolutely. And there's no protest. Similarly, when young people go to concerts, they open up their handbags, women open up their handbags, men are used to, were used to going through metal detectors. That just didn't happen decades ago. It didn't happen before 9-11. All of those changes were in direct response to a concern for terrorism. on our soil. Let me ask you a related question. Why is it important to mark anniversaries of tragic events? Do these bring back the trauma or do they help people process and cope with it or both? That's a very interesting question. One of the things that I think is really clear is inadvertently the media and even interviews like this bring forward again these events. I personally have been very unhappy to see images of the 9-11 attacks, graphic images of the 9-11 attacks, portrayed in the media. And for many years on the 9-11 anniversary, we would see pictures of the World Trade Center,
要么着火，要么人们满身煤烟地在街上奔跑，或者从窗户跳下。从窗户跳下，尽管这些画面在早期并没有被展示。事实上，媒体曾做出一些编辑决定，不在“9·11”发生后的几天和几周内展示其中一些血腥画面。我个人更喜欢看到一些画面，比如世贸中心原址上亮起的蓝色灯光，那是对人们失去的亲人的美丽纪念。这些与悲剧的画面截然不同。所以我认为，当媒体有这么多关于悲剧的报道时，我们很难避免想起这场悲剧。
either on fire or people running through the streets and filled with soot or, Jumping out of windows. Jumping out of windows, although those images were not shown in the early years. In fact, there were a number of editorial decisions made by the media not to show some of those graphic images in the days and weeks after 9-11. I personally have preferred seeing images of, there's some beautiful images of, blue lights coming up where the World Trade Center had been beautiful memorials to the loved ones that people lost. Those are very different from the images of the tragedy. So I think it's very difficult for us to avoid remembering the tragedy when there are so many media portrayals of the tragedy.
我们一遍又一遍地看到这些。我认为，当然，对于任何周年纪念，无论是生日或婚礼等积极事件的周年纪念，还是“9·11”或失去亲人等悲剧事件的周年纪念，我们当然都会想起那些日子里发生的事件。我不认为有人会主张我们试图忘记。当然，我们想要纪念那些我们失去的人。
that we see over and over again. I think, of course, that for any anniversary, anniversaries of positive events like birthdays or weddings or anniversaries of tragic events like 9-11 or the loss of a loved one, we, of course, think about the events on those days. I don't think in any way that anybody would advocate that we try to forget. Of course, we want to memorialize those who we lost.
我们想要保持警惕，以免我们所谈论的这类事件再次发生。让我们转换话题，谈谈许多人在过去一年半里经历的集体创伤。您今年早些时候写了一篇名为《应对美国的连锁集体创伤》的文章。您能解释一下“连锁集体创伤”这个词吗？我们刚刚经历的这一年有多么前所未有？嗯，我开始思考我们作为一个国家正在应对的创伤事件的连锁反应，是在我得知乔治·弗洛伊德在2020年5月（我相信是）不幸且悲惨地被谋杀的第二天早上。我当时实际上正躺在床上思考这件事。这一年是多么糟糕。
And we want to be vigilant so that the kinds of events that we're talking about don't occur again. Let's switch gears and talk about the collective traumas that many people have experienced in the last year, year and a half. You wrote an article earlier this year called Coping with Cascading Collective Traumas in the United States. Can you explain that term cascading collective traumas? How unprecedented is the year we've just had? Well, I started to think about the cascade of traumatic events that we as a country were dealing with the morning after I learned of George Floyd's untimely and tragic murder in May, I believe it was, of 2020. And I was actually lying in bed thinking about it in the morning. how terrible a year it had been.
我们当然是从认识到新冠病毒开始的。在早期，它甚至不叫这个名字，而是被称为新型冠状病毒。以及世界各地，或者至少在美国发起的广泛隔离。以及随之而来的经济影响，以及当时数百万人失去工作。我想到这些事件如何让人们有了很多空闲时间，比他们平时更多的空闲时间，对于许多人来说，当然那些仍在努力工作以维持我们国家运转的基本工作人员除外。但我意识到人们有很多空闲时间，
We began, of course, with the recognition of COVID. It wasn't actually called, it was called the novel coronavirus in the early days. And the widespread quarantines that were initiated across the world, or certainly in the United States. and the economic fallout from that and the millions of people who were losing their jobs at that time. And I thought about how these events led people to have a lot of time on their hands, more time on their hands than they, for many people, those who were certainly not the essential workers who were still working very hard to keep our country going. But I realized that people had a lot of time on their hands,
无论是看电视还是参与媒体、社交媒体。所以我们似乎已经准备好以一种我认为许多人已经意识到但并没有像我们在这种可怕的疫情背景下那样关注的方式，去了解乔治·弗洛伊德被谋杀的事件。大约在同一时间，当然是在乔治·弗洛伊德被谋杀后的几周和几个月里，我们西北部发生了野火。飓风的数量也有所增加，我
both to watch television or engage in media, social media. And so we were sort of primed to hear about the events or the murder of George Floyd in ways that I think we had been, many people had been aware of but not really focused on in the way that we were in the context of this terrible pandemic. Around the same time, certainly in the couple of weeks and months after George Floyd's murder, we had wildfires throughout the Northwest. There were increased numbers of hurricanes that had not been, I'd
相信2020年即使不是最糟糕的，也是美国有记录以来飓风最严重的年份之一。这一切似乎让人难以承受。所以我的同事艾莉森·霍尔曼、达纳·加芬和我写了一篇论文，正如你所说，名为《应对美国的连锁集体创伤》，我们在文中强调了直接接触这类经历以及通过媒体间接接触的重要作用。我们强调了人们监测自己接触悲剧媒体的重要性。我们承认，走出这一年将是非常困难的。我一直在思考我在疫情开始初期所做的采访和演讲。我当时说，我们
believe 2020 was, if not the worst, one of the worst years on record for hurricanes in the United States. And all of this just seemed almost too much to bear. So my colleagues, Alison Holman and Dana Garfin and I wrote a paper, as you said, called Cascade, coping with Cascading Collective Traumas in the United States, in which we highlighted the important role of both direct exposure to these kinds of experiences, as well as indirect exposure via the media. And we argued how important it was for people to monitor their exposure to media about tragedies. And we acknowledge that it was going to be a very difficult year to come out of. I have been thinking a lot about interviews and talks that I gave in the early days after the pandemic began. And I said at the time that we
不知道这场疫情会持续多久，也不知道它会变得多糟糕。而在2021年，遗憾的是，我仍然会这么说。我们真的不知道它会变得多糟糕。我们也不知道它会持续多久。当然，当我在2020年春天那样说的时候，我们还没有疫苗，但现在我们有了疫苗。并不是世界上所有想要接种疫苗的人都能获得疫苗。而在我们国家，许多有条件接种疫苗的人选择了不接种。所以我认为这使我们处于一个非常复杂的情况中，我们不知道它会持续多久，也不知道它会变得多糟糕。鉴于所有降临在我们身上的死亡、厄运和破坏，我的意思是，我们会在某个时候达到极限吗？我们会对这么多创伤变得麻木吗？还是它只会不断堆积？
don't know how long this pandemic is going to last and we don't know how bad it's going to get. And in 2021, sadly, I would still say the same thing. We really don't know how bad it's going to get. And we don't know how long it's going to last. Of course, when I said that back in the spring of 2020, we didn't have vaccines, but now we have vaccines. Not everybody in the world who would love to get a vaccine has access to it. And many people who have access to vaccines in our country have chosen not to get them. So I think that that puts us in a very complicated situation where we don't know how long it's going to last and we don't know how bad it's going to get. Given all the death, doom, and destruction that's been raining down on us, I mean, do we get
嗯，我认为我们必须认识到，并不是每个人都以同样的方式受到疫情的影响。所以有数以百万计的人失去了亲人。有数以百万计的人自己生病了。还有一些人因为经济状况或仅仅是运气，或者也许是因为警惕，而没有受到事件的个人影响，除了他们花更多时间待在家里。
maxed out at some point? Do we become inured to this much trauma and you just get numb? Or does it just pile and pile and pile up? Well, I think that we must recognize that everybody hasn't been impacted by the pandemic in the same way. So there are. Millions and millions of individuals who have lost a loved one. There are millions and millions of individuals who have gotten sick themselves. And there are some who have been fortunate because of their economic circumstances or just luck, or perhaps because of vigilance that have been personally untouched by the events, except that they are spending more time at home.
也许他们在园艺。我的意思是，疫情的接触范围和影响范围确实有所不同。毫无疑问，某些群体，特别是美洲原住民群体、拉丁裔个人、黑人居民，比其他人受到新冠导致的疾病和死亡的影响更大。所以我们必须认识到这一点。这不是一种“一刀切”的接触，也不会有一种“一刀切”的应对方式。我研究悲剧已经超过40年了，我在写博士论文时学到的最重要的信息，以及40年后的今天，就是没有“一刀切”的应对方式。人们处理和应对事件的方式存在巨大的差异，很大程度上受到人们先前生活经历、慢性压力或事件期间经历的影响，以及他们在事后拥有的支持和资源数量的影响。所有这些都说明这是一个复杂的情况，这就是为什么我们尝试收集数据，为什么我们尝试对这个主题进行研究。我的同事和
maybe they're gardening. I mean, the range of exposures and the range of impact of the pandemic has really differed. And there is no, it's no secret that there are certain groups, in particular, Native American groups, Latinx individuals, black residents who have been more impacted by the illness and the deaths as a result of COVID. than others. So we have to recognize it. It hasn't been a one-size-fits-all exposure, and there will not be a one-size-fits-all response. I've been studying tragedy for over 40 years, and the most important message that I learned back when I was working on my dissertation, and now 40 years later, is that there is not a one-size-fits-all response. There's enormous variability in how people process. and respond to events, very much influenced by people's prior life experiences, by their chronic stress or their experiences during the event, and by the amount of support and resources that they have in the aftermath. All of this is to say it's a complicated situation, and that's why we try to collect data, why we try to do research on this topic. My colleagues and
我多年来一直试图对这类问题进行方法论上严谨的系统性研究。当然，这取决于让其他人与我们分享他们的经历、情绪、感受、想法和担忧。但我们非常幸运。有成千上万的人参与了我的研究。我认为这有助于我认识到没有“一刀切”的应对方式。我当然不想暗示有，就像2020年的事件以不同的方式影响了人们一样。有一个研究领域关注所谓的“创伤后成长”。在某些情况下，人们可以在悲剧中找到意义，经历创伤时期可以激发积极的
I for many, many years have tried to conduct methodologically rigorous systematic research on these kinds of issues. Of course, it depends on getting others to share their experiences, their emotions and their feelings and their thoughts and concerns with us. But we have been very fortunate. I've had tens of thousands of people who have participated in my studies. And I think it helps me recognize that there is an 01-size-fits-all response. And I certainly don't want to imply that there is in the same way that the events of 2020 have impacted people in different ways. There's a field of study that looks at something called post-traumatic growth. In some cases, people can find meaning and tragedy and living through a traumatic time can spark positive
发展和个人成长。这是您在集体创伤研究中看到的情况吗？我个人认为人们看到的这些积极益处是一种应对策略。这是人们应对这种可怕的逆境和不确定性的方式。但我和同事们目前正在写一篇论文，研究疫情带来的积极体验。我们不使用“创伤后成长”这个词。
development and personal growth. Is that something you've seen in your research on collective trauma? I personally see these kinds of positive benefits that people see as a a coping strategy. This is the way in which people cope with this terrible adversity and uncertainty. But my colleagues and I are working on a paper right now looking at the positive experiences that have come out of the pandemic. We don't use the term post-traumatic growth.
这是我认为其他人可能会使用的词。我们将这些视为人们能够看到的益处，也许是人们为了应对悲剧而进行的心理体操。他们同时承认悲剧，但他们也看到了一些积极的体验。当然，许多许多人享受了在家工作的机会，不必坐在交通堵塞中。然后还有
That is something that I think others may use. We see these as benefits that people are able to see, perhaps their mental gymnastics that people are engaging in to cope with the tragedy simultaneously. They're acknowledging the tragedy, but they are seeing some positive experiences. Certainly many, many people have, enjoyed the opportunity to work from home and not have to sit in traffic. And then there are
其他人，还有其他个人被困在住所里，与虐待他们的人或与他们有非常复杂个人关系的人在一起。也许他们没有好的互联网。也许他们生活在一个使在家工作变得极其困难的环境中。因此，虽然有些人可能会发现不必坐在交通堵塞中的积极益处，但其他人却发现同样的经历相当令人压力和挑战。所以我认为，再次强调认识到有不同的应对方式很重要。我确实，我们发现许多人能够看到黑暗和阴郁中的一线希望。我确实认为这是一种非常积极的方式
others of, there are other individuals who are stuck in a residence with somebody who is abusive or somebody with whom they have a very complicated personal relationship. Maybe they don't have good internet. Maybe they are living in an environment that makes working from home extraordinary difficult. And so while some people may find the positive benefits of not having to sit in traffic, others find that same experience to be quite stressful and quite challenging. So we, I think it's important, again, to recognize that there are different ways to respond. I do, we, we have found that many people are able to see a somewhat silver or green. right, you know, lining in the blackness and the bleakness. And I do see that as a very positive way
来应对这种情况，因为否则它真的会让人不知所措。我们还没有在数据中深入挖掘这一点，但我一直在监测世界各地其他人报告的数据。我们确实知道，在一些社区，数据仍然很重要，我们需要探索不止一项研究。但看起来在一些社区，物质使用和物质滥用的比率可能有所增加。有一些文章指出，孤独的瘟疫导致了抑郁症的增加。我们在自己的数据中也看到了一些这种情况。我想，同样，我们将不得不看看后果是什么。
to cope with this, because otherwise it really can be overwhelming. We haven't exploited as much in our data yet, but I've been monitoring what others are reporting in data across the world. And we do know that in some communities or, and again, the data, data are still, it's important for us to explore more than one study. But it does look like in some communities, rates of substance use and substance abuse may have increased. There have been some articles suggesting that the plague of loneliness has led to increased depression. We've, We've seen some of that in our own data. I think, again, we'll have to see what the consequences are.
但与此同时，人们正在经历这些负面的心理状态，许多人正试图坚持他们所拥有的一些积极体验。我确实觉得，一旦我们走出困境，一旦我们度过了这段可怕的时光，我确实觉得人们很可能会回顾2020年的事件，发现他们比预期的更坚强，或者他们能够通过认识到一些他们没有意识到的技能而挺过来。但同样，这并不是说有些人将无法找到任何积极的东西。我的意思是，这确实是可怕的一年。对于那些失去了亲人、无法告别、无法举行仪式的人来说，
But at the same time that people are experiencing these negative psychological states, many people are trying to hold on to some positive experiences that they've had. And I do feel that once we're out of this, I think once we are through this terrible time, I do feel quite, I think it's likely that people will be able to look back on the events of 2020, 2020, and see that they were stronger than they had expected or that they were able to come through recognizing some skills that they didn't realize that they had. But again, that is not to say that there will be some who will be unable to find anything positive. I mean, this has really been a terrible year. And for people who have lost loved ones who were not able to say goodbye, who were unable to have a ritual,
所有这些事情都是可怕的。我不认为，我认为非常重要的一点是，我们不要暗示每个人都应该从中看到积极的东西，因为对一些人来说，这可怕的一年里没有任何积极的东西。我认为我们都遭受了损失，无论是真实的还是象征性的，婚礼的取消，或者无法庆祝高中最后一年，或者无法参加体育运动。我的意思是，所有这些发生在2020年的事情，我认为，都伴随着一些人，对于这些人来说，可能永远不会离开他们。我也不指望它会离开。您几年前发表了一篇关于“险些发生”经历的论文，发现那些
all of these things are just terrible. And I don't want, I think it's very important that we don't imply that everybody should be seeing something positive about this because for some there is nothing positive about this horrible year and I you know I think I think we have all suffered losses both real and symbolic the cancellation of weddings or the inability to celebrate one senior year in high school or the inability to play sports. I mean, all of these things that happened in 2020, I think, are with some people and will likely, for those individuals, never leave them. And I wouldn't expect that it would. You published a paper a couple of years ago about near-miss experiences that found people who
险些错过创伤事件的人更有可能经历创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）和幸存者内疚。您能谈谈那项研究吗？我和同事迈克尔·普伦写过一篇关于“9·11”后“险些发生”事件的论文。在我们约3500人的样本中，有100多人要么险些错过前往纽约的机会，要么险些错过登上飞机，或者有家庭成员险些直接受到“9·11”的影响。我可能会说我们没有说他们经历了PTSD。我们可能指出他们经历了一些压力症状，重要的是要认识到存在一种需要临床医生做出诊断的PTSD临床诊断。
narrowly missed a traumatic event were more likely to experience PTSD and survivors' guilt. Can you talk about that research? So there was a paper that my colleague Michael Pullen and I wrote about near misses after 9-11. We had in our sample of about 3,500, we had more than 100 individuals who had either nearly missed going to New York or nearly missed getting on an airplane or had a family member that nearly missed the possibility of. having been directly impacted by 9-11. And I would probably say we didn't say that they experienced PTSD. We probably indicated that they experienced some stress symptoms that are, and it's important to recognize that there is a clinical diagnosis of PTSD that requires a clinician
而且目前的临床诊断标准也要求人们直接接触悲剧。所以我们实际上是在看相反的情况，即那些刚刚错过经历悲剧的个人。所以他们实际上没有资格被诊断为PTSD，但他们更有可能经历创伤后应激症状。关于“险些发生”的研究很少。这是一个非常有趣且研究不足的话题，我认为随着我们回顾疫情，未来研究人员可能会对此感兴趣。当然，我们在“9·11”袭击后的第二波数据收集（我想是几个月后）中询问了人们是否经历过“险些发生”的事件，并让他们告诉我们一些相关情况。
to make that diagnosis. and also in the current clinical diagnostic criteria requires that people are directly exposed to a tragedy. So we are, in fact, looking at the opposite, individuals who just missed experience in a tragedy. So they wouldn't really be eligible to being diagnosed with PTSD, but they were more likely to experience post-traumatic stress symptoms. and there have been a few studies on near misses. It's a very interesting and understudied topic and one that I think will perhaps be of interest to researchers in the future as we look back on the pandemic. Of course, we asked people in the, I think, a few months after, I think that, It was the second wave of data collection after the 9-11 attacks, whether they had experienced a near-miss and how they, to tell us a little bit about that.
而且，确实有些人经历过，也许他们没有登上那架撞向世贸中心的飞机，但他们也打算登上飞往纽约的飞机。我的意思是，所有这些都会导致人们认识到他们因为没有登上那架飞机或没有去那栋大楼而受益，而其他人却经历了悲剧。这与一个被称为“幸存者内疚”的概念有关，即人们确实感到他们很幸运，而其他人则没那么幸运。我们在90年代初的男同性恋者中也发现了非常相似的心理经历，他们从事着导致一些男同性恋者感染艾滋病的相同活动。
And, you know, it is the case that some people experience, you know, maybe they weren't going to get on the exact plane that crashed into the World Trade Center, but they were also going to get on a plane going to New York. I mean, all of these can lead people to recognize that they benefited by not having gotten on that airplane or by not having gone to the building and others experienced tragedy. And that has been linked to a concept that is called survivor guilt, that people do feel a sense that they were lucky and that. Others were not so lucky. And we also found very similar psychological experiences in the early 90s among gay men who were engaged in the very same activities that led some gay men to get AIDS. and these individuals were spared at random. And my colleagues and I wrote a paper about what it was actually entitled Spared at Random.
而这些人是随机幸免的。我和同事写了一篇关于它的论文，标题实际上是《随机幸免》。
And it was about individuals who had really somehow by luck or good fortune just didn't contract AIDS, although they could report activities that they had done that had been quite similar. But this is, of course, all before we understood how AIDS was transmitted. And they had that same feeling of guilt? Yes. Yes. Yes. A sense of survivor guilt.
它是关于那些确实以某种方式通过运气或好运没有感染艾滋病的人，尽管他们报告的活动与那些感染的人非常相似。但这当然是在我们了解艾滋病如何传播之前。他们有同样的内疚感吗？是的。是的。是的。一种幸存者内疚感。
It was actually this concept of survivor guilt was formulated about individuals who survived the Holocaust. And they were individuals who had been in a concentration camp, but nonetheless had managed to get out and live beyond that. So, you know, these are very interesting from a psychological standpoint. phenomenon. You know, fortunately, we don't have that many opportunities to study these kinds of events. But when we do, they help us understand, again, the range of exposures and the range of responses to tragedy. So to sum up, do you have any advice for listeners on how to cope when they're feeling stressed or anxious or overwhelmed by the cascading collective traumas of the past year. Is there anything that can do to inoculate themselves against post-traumatic stress or anxiety?
实际上，这种“幸存者内疚”的概念是针对大屠杀幸存者提出的。他们是那些曾被关在集中营，但最终设法逃脱并活下来的人。所以，这些从心理学角度来看是非常有趣的现象。幸运的是，我们没有那么多机会研究这类事件。但当我们这样做时，它们再次帮助我们理解了悲剧的接触范围和应对范围。总结一下，对于听众在感到压力、焦虑或被过去一年的连锁集体创伤压得喘不过气时，您有什么建议吗？有什么方法可以让他们预防创伤后应激或焦虑吗？
Well, certainly if individuals feel overwhelmed and unable to cope, I would encourage them and have encouraged people to reach out to clinicians. There are hotlines that are available if people are feeling overwhelmed and feeling that they really need to connect with others. I think there have been new forms of mental health treatments that have moved, let's say, to telehealth, to communicate with health care providers virtually rather than in person. But I certainly think that if individuals feel overwhelmed, they should reach out to both loved ones and to health care professionals, their health care professionals, mental health professionals. I also encourage people to the extent to which it's possible to monitor their media intake,
嗯，当然，如果个人感到不知所措且无法应对，我会鼓励他们，也一直鼓励人们向临床医生寻求帮助。如果人们感到不知所措，觉得真的需要与他人联系，可以使用热线电话。我认为已经出现了新的心理健康治疗形式，比如远程医疗，通过虚拟方式而不是面对面与医疗保健提供者沟通。但我当然认为，如果个人感到不知所措，他们应该向亲人和医疗保健专业人员、他们的医疗保健专业人员、心理健康专业人员寻求帮助。我还鼓励人们在可能的情况下监测他们的媒体摄入量，
to be mindful of the amount of time that they spend immersed in reading bad news. Certainly in 2020, it was all bad news all the time. And I think it's extremely important that people recognize how much time they may be spending immersed in this bad news. Journalists have called this doom scrolling. I had not heard the term until some journalists contacted me to ask me what I thought about it. But it makes sense where somebody could sit at a computer or with a smartphone and just click on link after. after link after link, and five hours later, they have just been immersed in reading stories about tragedy. So I do encourage people to monitor the amount of time that they're spending. I am in no way
注意他们沉浸在阅读坏消息上的时间。当然在2020年，全是坏消息。我认为人们认识到他们可能花多少时间沉浸在这些坏消息中是非常重要的。记者们称之为“末日刷屏”（doom scrolling）。在一些记者联系我询问我的看法之前，我还没有听说过这个词。但这很有道理，一个人可以坐在电脑前或拿着智能手机，一个接一个地点击链接，五个小时后，他们就一直沉浸在阅读关于悲剧的故事中。所以我确实鼓励人们监测他们花费的时间。我绝不
advocating any kind of censorship, and I am in no way suggesting that people put their head in the sand. What I'm suggesting is that people monitor the amount of time, maybe check the news morning, noon, evening, rather than spending a lot of time reading about tragedy. And I think that that's recognizing that, recognizing and being mindful of one's own feelings and the need and recognition that it's appropriate to reach out to loved ones or to health care professionals or mental health professionals, as well as monitoring the amount of time that one is spending immersed in tragic news, I think, are two very important ways in which we can cope with these very difficult times. Excellent advice. Thank you for joining us today, Dr.
主张任何形式的审查，也绝不建议人们掩耳盗铃。我建议的是人们监测时间，也许在早晨、中午、晚上查看新闻，而不是花大量时间阅读关于悲剧的内容。我认为，认识到这一点，意识到并关注自己的感受，以及认识到向亲人或医疗保健专业人员或心理健康专业人员寻求帮助是适当的，以及监测自己沉浸在悲剧新闻中的时间，我认为这是我们应对这些非常困难时期的两种非常重要的方法。非常好的建议。感谢您今天参加我们的节目，西尔弗博士，来反思这个周年纪念日。非常感谢您的邀请。我非常感谢这个机会。您可以在www.com或Apple、Stitcher或您获取喜爱的播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目，请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有评论或想法，可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是Speaking of Psychology，连在一起，at apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·怀纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪恩。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Silver, to reflect on this anniversary. Thank you so much for having me. I really appreciate the opportunity. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www.com or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts, and please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speakingof psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyion. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Silver，在这个周年纪念日进行反思。非常感谢您邀请我。我真的很珍惜这次机会。您可以在 www.com 或 Apple、Stitcher 或您获取喜爱的播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》往期节目，请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是 Speaking of Psychology，连在一起，在 APA.org。 《心理学谈话》由 Lee Wynerman 制作。我们的声音编辑是 Chris Condyion。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的 Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。